we're here to talk about Mirror's Edge
catalyst a sequel prequel type effort
reimagining long time in the making i
mean Mirror's Edge feels like you know
that's an early xbox 360 game that's a
game that's been around for a long time
I played a bit of it on pc earlier I saw
that still looks all right it does but
what we were playing over the weekend
was the beta for catalyst which I was
playing on xbox one where we pop kiss
for your playing PS for Mike you didn't
play did you I didn't get a chance but
you have played mirrors edges in the
past oh yeah you've been on a mirror's
edge or two yes ok ok so that's kind of
chew into it I feel like I have like I'm
a big fan of the first message well
himself actually our plane okay that's
actually perfect right sort of way of
coming into this so I came in looks sort
of like rather lofty expectations of
what I would like from this game and I
feel like I've kind of gone a bit all
over the place with it um and I'm still
not really sure exactly Ryland you
coming in fresh into it playing on
PlayStation 4 what did you think Kallis
i really enjoyed it um if I can make any
comparison I'd say you're like off the
bat as far as parkour games I played
like dying light that's a little
reminiscent as far as like the feel and
you know doing cool moves yeah i thought
the parkour and this game was
spectacular i didn't have any issues
maybe gripes not all like it was a
really fun experience I enjoyed it I you
know it's a cool city at first I was a
little I went two ways first I was like
oh this is a really bland world looks
like an apple store right and then no I
was like oh this is actually more of a
cool environment I like the setup a
steno this utopian city yeah game a lot
of like um equilibrium vibes you know
right what yeah these guys are trying to
do basically put down people like no
emotions from you you know like 90-84 or
something then he just sure gon cut gun
Katya whatever the hell it's kolkata gun
connor grab with nine clerics and then i
had a third wind of this is getting a
little boring right um looking at like a
room and it's just these glasses that
I'm like the glasses on a table and it
it looks like just
app yeah none of this book this doesn't
look that great and it gets boring and
I'm you know you walk into a room and I
just it's like box uh and that got old
for me it's a weird sort of dystopian
utopia I guess for the for people who
haven't played the original or people
have the original don't know what this
event basically what they've done with
mirrors edges it's now in a sort of open
world and I mean open world is maybe a
bit of a stretch it's just a large area
like a large level which I'm sure opens
up lard you can bake her when you get
into beta and then the biggest problem
that was with mirrors edge the first one
of the biggest criticism which most
players and reviewers had was that the
gun combat in that game was like a big
issue like it you had the option to
shoot people or he could keep running in
the first game and and then later on in
the first game you there were like two
or three levels that were at the end of
the game which was essentially were
forced to use a gun and it didn't work
well and even though this was the same
studio who's made battlefield of course
and dice and so what they've done in
this is that they've basically made it
so most of the lower level enemies that
you encounter only use truncheon so they
only used batons basically to beat you
down and the main mechanic that they've
added like most of the running is almost
identical to Mirror's Edge they've added
a bunch of like extra types of movements
in wash most of it seems to be around
the combats like jumping off walls to
take people down and or jumping off
walls and pushing people out of the way
they've sort of split the combat in two
ways one is like I'm hitting them to get
past them it's like a traversal attack
and then the other one is like a heavy
attack which is all I'm actually trying
to kill this person right but they sort
of push you in the direction of not
trying to get everyone because there's
this flow meter which you kind of you
build up as you the more you run so
there are people who shoot you yet Iran
and and that they call it shoot dodge
shield yeah so later on guy you will you
you will get guy shooting at you and the
ideas you have you right have that meter
filled in order to have that like
secondary shield against bullets and
then use your parkour to like take them
out or or whatever which is cool right
it's like yeah if you build up enough
flowed and basically you can dodge
bullets and that's kind of like a cool
you know conceit yeah it's fine like
this um I got different takes on they
they they would implement it like
different ways right like you hear yo
here's point A to point B don't buy
anyone yeah like these are mission
elements and the other one be like now
you got no you actually gotta fight
these guys so is a mixture of both I
guess and you can knock if you want you
can like engage in the fight and knock
down somebody or knock them into someone
else another person or get them close to
the edge of a you know corner and then
knock them off and what a kind of
reminded me of is that I really like
using like melee weapons in games like
Skyrim or Oblivion but there are some
people who will not touch that who like
will never play a med a build in one of
those games and first-person melee
combat is like such an incredibly
difficult thing to do right and I think
they've kind of done a pretty good job
of it but at the end of the day it's
just never that compelling like I was
sort of using and I'm putting most of my
tech stuff into my movement and not
necessarily my combat stuff to basically
get rid of them and then there's this
and this is the sort of stuff that's
like weird for a beta right because you
don't really know how this is pretty
close to release they pushed it back i
think too like a week before you three
or something like I've gotten there and
but it's coming there pretty soon so
some of the stuff I'm not sure if it's
fair to lay on it because it is a beta 1
this game does not look great no I know
and the first game when it came out on
xbox 360 it was very striking it was
very it was linear so then they could
there's that whole thing if you have a
game that is relatively you know buxton
then you can add more visually striking
elements to it because you're not
worried about people going outside and
and having to load more stuff or
whatever I don't know again drew that
that obviously doesn't exist in this one
the other thing is that like the
original game fell very cinematic like
this sort of like weird future luc
besson type world that's kind of crazy
and like you said like looks like an
apple store but you kind of like ads
like a linear weird story I'm on it when
you spread that out into an open world
it just doesn't make any sense it's like
why is everything so clean why is
everyone so idealistic why are none of
these characters in any way believable
but like the mission people were just
standing around on rooftops and if if
you're not willing to give you the
mission they literally just stand there
yeah I saw somebody who's standing there
what a rooftop not a [ __ ] rooftop
like by the way it's like 15 stories up
or something on a rooftop and I'm like
why you standing here and they don't do
anything and later on their a mission
giver but they were there at a whole
time or how about there was one guy who
I did a runner mission for her and I
gave it I gave him the
that work and in he's still standing
there yeah after I did his mission he's
just hanging out name isn't he didn't
talk to you know yeah also that mission
was the weirdest voiceover I like person
gives you something to give to somebody
instead of using a courier system
they're using you because of this sort
of political reason and then when you
run away from her she's talking to you
in your ear I like how were you talk
like I'm sure to some future oh it's a
good thing we invented the squabbit
Blair so everyone can like talk to each
other like there's just so much of that
there's no consistency the world it
didn't feel real at all faiths feel was
really not great at all so I can't I
thought the voice acting in the
cinematics was actually top-notch I was
really into that that was that's just
right but yeah you can get into her
character but I have to say one thing
there was an area when I was doing I was
you know you can do side missions like
go hack this billboard and I'm climbing
on this area and like oh there's people
in this room oh I'm looking in weed Jake
deccan hide to the live stream of the 12
people in this room yeah four of them
are right exactly the same on the phone
in like in a line Larry people in a line
all the same that's a bummer and yeah
hopefully that's not present there's
another scene where I was looking down a
bit between two buildings and a drone
did you look at the drones falling by
rhyme of them literally their their fans
are just triangles right yeah it's
that's frightening to me like I I bet
this game would look a lot better on pc
and the weird thing about it is this
game when you stream it on the Internet
looks really good it like has the
opposite effect of Far Cry fashion I
just write the guy yeah yeah the
compression helps us yeah whereas with
the added detail you have on your own
home television there's just something
about it looks so edgy in like a not
very sort of a pleasing type way and
like that's just not you and me like
I've heard that across the board from a
lot of people who played is that it
doesn't look super I don't know to me
this feels so much like Mirror's Edge
one in like all the right ways in all
the wrong ways and like the traversal
zone is very very identical the unlock
system is like they're like peering at
bits and bobs to you because I feel like
they're trying to teach you how to do
this no this whole combat thing but it
feels like an open-world game that also
was made in 2007
but it doesn't feel like a real flesh
that world to me at all did you look at
the skill tree like like the one thing
they blocked off about half of what the
skill tree yeah I think maybe there's
like three does like move in combat in
something else gear here okay um if you
look down on some of like the combat
ones some of like the the trees are just
damaged more like more damaged more
damage early I don't know where these I
was looking through them like we're the
moves you know I expect something along
the lines of that not just like damage
against these guys damage against these
guys and the thing that was like pushing
you forward in the first message and
again this is difficult to love it as
criticism on a beta but yeah the thing
that was like was the fact that this is
a linear story based game you were going
to new environments which was always
sort of the the fun element was like oh
this next level is going to look
beautiful in the new way or like there
was the level you had to like go down in
the circle around you all that yeah and
they yeah and then it was like loads of
like sort of sewer retype levels and
stuff like that and I don't know I've
been treading a lot of common Greta no
pun intended I common ground in this
game like over and over again and I I
don't like even if they do mix it up I
don't know that the next area is going
to be a shell so the thing that's like
that they're trying to like push you
forward with the unlocks and and all
that that's not compelling enough for me
to keep playing I felt like I once they
just spent you know what I like
exploring open-world games I'm just
going to go on and explore and I went
lalalalalala and I'm like one of the
things that I want our biggest
criticisms of watch dogs is that you
could be anywhere and wash dogs and if
somebody asks you to go back to your
house you would have a clue like it's
just nothing about the world like a game
like GTA kind of have an idea right
there's like low i noticed street yeah
right exactly you treat look different
yeah your sense of the place you're
actually taking in the face Mirror's
Edge catalyst to me was just like I'm
running Patrick could be i don't know
where i am and i ran to like the and i
played for like three hours something i
wrote and it relatively small areas not
that big and I ran to the farthest reach
of us to be like oh where does the map
stop and it was this concourse that was
about like six lanes wide was the way
they split you off in the city and I
just felt I want to go over there I'll I
go down there I want to go I'm just
stuck on the roofs and it feels really
weird even your main I mean you can this
is better right I don't know what's
going to be in infra stores but
your main hub it seemed like there were
only two ways of exiting yeah in that
you were going down lanes that that over
time got repetitive yeah I'm hoping
there are a mean you know yeah I only
play for like four or five hours but
like I hope there are lanes that you can
start you know making up your own more
of that like because when you initially
leave it's just it's like the same route
I've done this route before and yeah at
first the same 30 seconds both ways is
exactly and I I feel like if you haven't
played a game like dying light maybe you
come off this completely different if
you haven't played a lot of like
first-person open-world games which have
like half decent traversal like I even
think like far cry primal to me is a
game that's like that's a fun game about
exploring the world and trying to like
you know i don't know like i enjoy the
movement in that game and like the
combat in that game far more than i
enjoy the movement in combat in this and
it's it's this is fine but like and then
I just feel like we're dying light
especially you've got a game that does
parkour pretty well does come shooting
really good and even those driving in a
new one really good so to me this game
just feels like oh you've made a sequel
to a game which at the time was doing a
lot of new things but in 2016 isn't
doing anything new so I don't know where
they had room to grow and even even
dying light started in room at nighttime
you got you have crazy threat in this
environment there's yeah there's
practically no npcs yeah there's no real
threat you get this decay sec guys but
in in that playthrough of the beta there
were only these like out boats outpost
security points yeah where you would go
into one of those and then you would
engage them and then the UDA you know
you'd have this chase it be cool if
there was more of a chase you be cool if
it was so unexpected they just they're
on to you now now you know two stars GTA
okay cool now I have to change up my my
way of what does if you're just
wandering around mid mission at like I
wanted REM admission for probably about
an hour last night maybe 45 minutes and
didn't run into any other they're not
there are only emissions yeah yeah so it
seems very strange yeah it's tough it
feels like a tough game the first
mirrors I just to make a sequel to write
because it's just the thing I loved
about it was linear but they're still
but alternate routes you could take
through that world that your reversal
felt good
and I like that they didn't force
weapons on you for the majority of the
game at the same time I think we're past
the point where we need to stop just
throwing open world onto a game just for
the sake of saying that's a feature
because you know like far cry primal is
a good example I think that game made
awesome use of its open world that's
what I'm worried about catalyst it
doesn't look like it's going to yet I
have not touched the beta so I don't
know but that's what I'm that's why I'm
tempering my expectations yeah it does
release and I think that's probably what
we're doing is like trying to temper I'm
not saying this is bad it was fine i
enjoyed it but it's not it's it's not
the feeling you got when you played
Mirror's Edge get one it feels and that
this is a beta I like people in the chat
are making good points like you know cbw
86 saying the map debate is one district
of around three or four and there's an
underground area to sure sure it does
expand sure but like you can gain a
certain amount of knowledge from the
loop that they give you in these things
and that's the sort of come up that I'm
getting from this is that like okay I
know what game you are and it's like
that's fine I'm where I'm just worried
like will the open-world aspect kill
what I liked about the first game
because I know you need to do something
different the sequel enough to set it
apart but will the open-world sacrifice
what makes that parkour so intriguing to
me yeah like the time try these stuff
that was in me resides one like I didn't
touch it all I just like the single
player but like that's a lot of what the
side missions and this seems to be very
like point-to-point races and their
knowing that different no there's a dash
and then there's a shoot there's another
one is the ones where you're getting the
security chips as well which essentially
is just an elongated version of a
point-to-point it's a point-to-point but
there's four points and I mean so they
feel very similar it's like right Oh
instead of going to the checkered flag
I'm just hitting exit a box you know
some of them are I mean both are
essentially do this as fast as you can
it's the same you're getting the same
drive one of them is just like if you
can't do it in two minutes you gotta do
it again yeah or are you doing a race
it's like all the way you get one star
mmm come back again if you want to you
know get two stars and there's probably
some cool stuff were like you unlock new
abilities and then you figure out faster
roots of doing these days but you're
just still doing point-to-point races
like that's like the one side mission
that open world games have tried to get
rid of for the past five years so yeah
it seems a little bit weird I don't know
huh Mirror's Edge comas it's
I did like it like I enjoyed it I was
really down on it for the first like
couple hours and then I think when I saw
going out I think then when I had the
expectation of what it was and I'm
Esther I'm a little bit more I was
calling yeah yes I guess smears edge so
yeah I guess I'll find out more soon
that was the the sort of smaller beta
they've done and not sure after opening
it up to any more it's been pushed back
though a little while so you're going to
have to wait and see to get your own
catalyst on let us know what you think
are you excited for it are you tempering
expectations they do not play the first
one you're looking to get into it let us
know if you play dying light as well
think it's a good game to compare it
with gentlemen thank you so much